(audience cheering)
- I forget.
- Thank you so much for having me.
I never know what to do now.
Like, hi, thank you.
- Like last time you were
here and it was virtual,
but you revealed to me
that you had never had
chocolate gummy bears
which is a travesty.
- I know, I'm sorry.
- So have you had one yet?
- No.
I didn't, I've been saving myself.
- I thought that you would disappoint me,
so I brought you some and I
feel like this is your moment.
- Let's do this
- This, okay.
Oh, we have our own bowl.
- Okay.
- We have our bowl.
- It's like a thick coating of chocolate.
- I mean, well, why not?
- Are they like,
is it like a normal gummy
bear or I'll find out.
- [Kelly] It's awesome. It's awesome.
And depending on what flavor you can get.
You're not into it?
- I don't know, Kelly.
- Fine. Give me the bowl.
- I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
- Give me the bowl.
- It's, I think it's a textural thing.
- [Kelly] Is it?
I like both these things
on their own, together.
- These are two beautiful
worlds coming together
in my mouth for a party right now.
- I have to say it does get better.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The initial thing I was not a fan of.
- Let it sit there.
- But you gotta sort of let
it marinate for a while.
- [Kelly] Mm hmm.
- Yeah.
- So wait, speaking of
like, American treasures.
Is it true that The Simpsons was like,
kind of how you learned about America?
- Yeah. I feel like for a lot of people
growing up in England like,
there are things I know about
America and American culture.
Like by the time I was
eight years old I was like,
Bismark is the capital of North Dakota.
And I know that because of the Simpsons.
And I feel like there's a
ton of just like movie stuff
and references to things
that I did not understand
when I was watching the show.
And then I saw those
movies like 10 years later
and I was like, oh, A Clockwork Orange.
Or like Indiana Jones.
like, oh, that was what that was.
And yeah, that was I
think a big introduction
to like all American culture.
- It's not far off, you know, the show.
It's not far off.
- I think it's a, I mean, it's like.
If you wanted to like, just,
if you came to earth tomorrow
and had to quickly educate
somebody about the last 30 years
of American culture, you could do worse
than doing The Simpsons.
- I'm just saying, it is a great show
but I don't know that it's great
to be that that's our thing.
- I don't know, I think.
- But I do think it's true.
- You only get, oh, this is the thing
I always say to Americans as well.
Is you only get like
the best of British TV.
That's why you all think we're like
smart and sweet and nice.
And you see Bake Off and that's great.
But like, but there's a
world of other British TV
that you don't see that's very bad.
- I grew up on Faulty Towers.
- [Daniel] That's exceptional.
- Oh my god, it's exceptional.
Yeah. And Are You Being
Served, I don't know if you.
- Oh, so I loved Are You Being Served.
That is of its time, but it's great.
- It is amazing.
- Yeah.
It's fantastic.
My, like that and a
show called 'Allo 'Allo,
which is just a bunch of English people
doing bad French accents the whole time.
- Oh my God.
I would love this show.
- You really would.
Again, it's like, it was a moment in time.
You couldn't do it now,
but it was very funny.
- I think we could do it
now. Just lean in, it's fun.
- I don't think France would be happy.
- People need to relax.
So wait, so you've been
known to do some karaoke
and I heard that like,
one of your famous people
that you go to is also mine.
- Oh, really?
- You love doing Eminem?
- I do. Well, yeah.
- I do too.
i feel like people expect
me to sing, so i rap.
And i love Eminem.
- I also like, I feel like if you were
if you came of age at a certain time like,
we were a bunch of the, you know,
the whitest middle class
kids in England being like,
i need to internalize all the
lyrics to Real Slim Shady.
Like it was, yes.
i know that, so i'm always
like amazed how well
i know some songs when i go to do karaoke.
Oh, this is like in there
- But it's like when we
were in like, junior high.
I feel like that's the time
we memorized everything.
Like, those are the songs I know by heart.
- I feel like it's a lot of, it's very
like the music that means the most
to you when you're a teenager.
- It's you're coming of age.
- It's very hard to
replicate that later, yeah.
- I know, I agree.
And it was good music.
So you often karaoke with your girlfriend.
Y'all been together for, is it 10 years?
- [Daniel] It'll be 10
years this year, yeah.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- [Daniel] Yeah. Thank you very much.
- [Kelly] It's Erin, right?
- [Daniel] Yeah
[Kelly] Oh my gosh.
that is amazing, 10 years.
[Kelly] So do y'all karaoke together?
- We do.
- Goes for too well, cause
also like in real slim shady
there's a very long chorus where a lot
of times you have to
say, well, the real stand
- Stand up.
- So she does a lot of that.
She's like very good at yeah.
- She your hype girl
- Yeah, she does.
and also we, we have done
we do a lot of like, we've done some duets
- Like grease.
- No, we do.
- You should lean in?
- there's this what?
I always forget the name of it.
Its all coming back to me now.
- Oh my God.
Celine Deon
- Yeah, yeah. Celine Deon
Yeah. We like go for that.
And that is again a that's one
of the like that's a longer song.
- It's it's like seven minutes.
i feel like
- The extended version
and there are some insane
and great lyrics in it.
Yeah. It's
- And some dramatic pauses.
- Yes. Yeah.
Long solos where you
just have to be up there.
- Yeah. Feeling it.
Yeah. Maybe some interpretive movement.
Yes.
- I don't Erin's a good
dancer though. Yeah
- I love it.
I wanna see Erin carry you.
So, so wait.
So was it there a time that you wore, I
this is brilliant to me.
You wore the same outfit pretty
much for like six months?
- Yeah. For, i think it
was there wasn't quite that
but it was like three or four months.
cause i was doing a play in London
and there was every night there
was like paparazzi outside.
and i suddenly realized after
like i had just been lazy
and not changed my clothes
for a few days that they were not there.
And i realized that they, oh
it's probably because i'm
wearing the same thing.
So it all looked like
photos from the same day.
So then i was just like, I'll
just continue wearing this,
they never came back.
- Because it looks like the same picture
- It all just looks like the same picture.
- You have
Just the like cured a lot
of people's issues right
now. It
- It's not foolproof that, you
know, they're still, you know
it, it didn't solve
everything, but it was any
I feel like, you know,
- I was just saying
that its not as exciting
- The small victories
of Anne's paparazzi is always
the ones you have to like
celebrate.
- That's a giant one.
I thought you were brilliant.
- Thank you very much
- I'm steal a friend it.
- A friend also got me a jacket once
which is like made out
of reflective material.
So if someone takes a flash photo
so it just like flashes
out the entire thing.
- But meanwhile, you
look like a disco ball.
like everywhere you go, that's also...
- Yes you look, it's not
it's as cool as something
like that can look, but
function is something else.
- Okay.
okay. Cuz i just pictured
you just dancing everywhere
you're going in this jacket
that's what I wanted to be.
So the new movie is great,
i loved every minute of it
It's it's funny.
- Yeah.
- It's you play a really good, bad guy.
can you tell everybody about
it that hasn't seen it?
- Yeah, sure.
So it's a movie where
San, the incredible Sandra
Bullock plays romance novelist
who gets, who my character
thinks has the genuine key
to finding some real life
treasures. So he does what
anyone would do, which is to
kidnap her and force her
to try and do his bidding.
And then Channing Tatum, who
is Sandra's cover model thinks
that it is his job to go and save her.
And it is truly like them together is one
of the most charming, like
lovely things you'll see
on the screen all year.
So really it is, it is so much fun.
- Its such a great cast,
a great the chemistry,
the randomness of it's so great.
And it involves like so many movies.
I feel like
for my childhood, but
they're all combined it's
- Yeah. I, I actually like
I had watched the mummy
the Brenda Frager, reg mum.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah I loved it.
- around the time I read the script
and it felt like that to me, just
like a great like adventure
film where everyone's the
the stakes are really high all the time
but everyone's being really
quickly and funny still, but you
like care about them and yeah,
it's just, it's a lot of fun.
- It, I think I'm older than you.
It reminded me too of
like a little bit of like
ING the stone, like jewel
and Nile, like the Kathleen
and Turner, Michael
Douglas kind of stuff too.
- That was brought up a lot
- It was like, that's been
yeah. It was, oh it has? Oh okay
- Lot of people know a lot of the style
- I love it, but it's totally different
because the chemistry's different,
the cover model thing is amazing.
- Yeah.
- It's all different, but it's just
it reminds me of those
like adventure films.
- It's those adventure films.
But it's, I think it's like
with a slightly like harder
edge towards the comedy as well.
Like it's genuinely,
it's very, very funny.
And there's like very,
very good action scenes.
There is a, there is a cameo that I don't
think I have to keep a secret anymore.
- No, everybody knows
- Everyone knows back in the
movie and Brad pits, like it's
- Amazing
- Actually sequencing this
film is so good, so funny.
- The hair flying
- Yeah. It's it's awesome.
- It's like everything
Channing Tatum's character
wants to be, it's amazing.
- Channing, that scene
is, oh, it's so funny.
- I also love how you say Sandra.
- I know, Well i also have to like
- I'm Texan,
I say Sandra.
- Well, yeah.
That's, that's probably
how you say it sounds great
- But she sounds very Regal
when you say it, she sounds
very fancy, Sandra(in British accent)
- She ask you to call her
Sandy as well, which was
a huge mental hurdle for me
cuz I'm just like put your Sandra Bullock.
I, I can't
- Oh my God. You can call her Sandy?
She would like you to,
- I'm not there yet.
- That's I felt like I was
never there, but she's like
please call me Sandy.
- Oh my God.
That's okay, Sandy, come on(laughing)
- She that's, yeah.
- We had a moment we drank together anyway
so Sandra's character plays,
she writes guilty pleasure novel.
So what's your guilty pleasure
or do you believe in it?
- That's The thing I don't
really believe in guilty
Pleasures I feel like at one
time I would refer to my love
of like reality tv and the
bachelor as a guilty pleasure.
But I now just have to admit
that I'm unironicly enjoying
it's it's it's yeah.
So I, I guess that like
I didn't watch the most recent series
of bachelor cuz I've been
doing press and stuff
but I hear it was mental
but for the end anyway, but, but yeah
so love is blind also took
up a lot of time during film.
- Wait does Erin get you into these?
Or you the one that's like so...
- She got me into it initially
but now I have to own the
fact that I'm also like, Hey
you want to put on Love's clients.
- I love it.
Good. So you and y'all got together
for a sitdown recently
for Harry Potter reunion
recently.
You were so young.
- Yeah.
- And I think that's kind of cool
cuz we all had so many
memories probably together
when you were that young.
- Yeah. No, it was, it was awesome.
Like to, I didn't know how
I would feel going back
and it was actually
incredibly lovely to like
see everyone again and
- Yeah
People that you've only had
like childhood conversations
with that you actually then
get to talk to as adults yet.
It was, it, it did end up
being really, really special.
And there are some memories
that you only, like
I don't know you that
only come back to you when
you are kind of there
together or remembering stuff.
So yeah, it was, it was very, very, yeah
it was really special.
- That's so cool.
I, I recently literally
my kids asked to go
on separate dates, but they
both wanted to go to universal.
Okay. And they both wanted
to see Harry Potter.
- Yeah.
- And so we, we went to the
ride and I kept the thinking.
Have you ever like snuck in
there to, to do the ride?
- I've not snuck in.
I went the, I went to
the opening when they
opened in Florida, I went to the one
there.
- It Would be amazing if you
snuck in and then just took
off your hat on the ride
and looked to the left
or something, heard the
right. Maybe it would be amazing.
- The people just be like,
this ride is amazing.
It's like really?
They thought
- Does this happen?
- Does everyone get this.
But yeah, no there's also,
they just opened the store.
There's like a massive Harry
Potter store in New York now.
And I'm often like walking
to a friend's house.
- What?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I'm a nerd.
- Oh
- I'm keeping it in.
- You should totally go.
- But like, okay.
I am gonna go.
- Yeah.
But I not like walk past there
and I'll suddenly get there
I'm like, oh no, I'm here
I have to, I have to not
be here very quickly.
Have to run before somebody sees me.
Yeah.
- That's awesome.
Or exciting for a lot of people.
Well, we are such fans.
The movie is amazing.
- Thank you so much.
It's so good. Thank you for coming by
thank you for trying our nasty chocolate
Daniel Redcliff everybody